j'ai attrapé le problème c'était pour
porter mes courses le problème c'est
qu'on a plus de forces est
habituellement je fais mes courses et je
rentre à pied je fais c'est à peu près
un quart d'heure de chez moi mon magasin
est là bas j'ai pas pu les porter voilà
donc je j'ai enfin je lis ou moins
graves que
faux je me suis fait tatouer l'intérieur
de l'estomac tout ça c'est tous ses
frères et soeurs c'était long c'est un
peu douloureux
faut jamais j'essaie de pas prononcé ce
mot
good man faux mes soeurs ne m'appelle
pas valoches je m'appelle grand string
grand str qui est le diminutif de grands
string après fucking big string et
l'anglais de grands string et maintenant
sbs qui est qu'ils sont les initiales de
fucking big string
oui vrai pourquoi vous allez changer de
nom pour prendre des libertés parce
qu'elle vit parce qu'elle est plus jeune
que moi là plein de choses fausses
mais j'espère qu'on le parfum du vrai
oui ça c'est vrai avec de l'huile
j'aurais vide est détruite je pense et
j'aurais aimé psychanalyste aussi être
costumière aussi mais vidé les truites
c'est quand même le oui
ouais c'est moi qui chante dans le film
je chante très bien j'ai beaucoup de
talent et je chante très haut c'est faux
c'est victoria ci-haut qui chante
merveilleusement la voix d'aline
vrai mais les gens le mettent à l'envers
sert le côté caoutchouc se met sur la
table pour pour pas que ça glisse ça
c'est un peu un truc de famille j'en ai
jeunes sur tout mais table
vrai ça n'a pas été simple préfère
pouvoir parler c'est ça mon mode
d'expression être mannequin
d'abord j'ai rien mangé pendant quinze
jours pour ses rentrées dans un costume
rien du tout donc je me suis à moitié
évanoui en vain en sortant j'ai eu plus
peur que de faire un spectacle entier
pendant que de jouer deux heures sur
scène de passer ça me manque ce que je
dis de 3 minutes et il m'avait fait une
coiffure comme ça qu'a mis dix jours à
décembre parce qu'il est tellement créé
pays l'ont fait avec mes propres cheveux
et j'avais une tête voilà c'était
compliqué à retirer
sourire
lever les sourcils
merde ça
faux ils ont
ils sont chez moi
dans une bibliothèque
faut je suis dragon et il ya plein de
gens qui attendent patiemment pour avoir
des bébés dragons donc on sent que c'est
un bon signe
j'ai vu quand on m'a dit que c'était un
chine classe je viens moi j'ai un ami
qui faisait croire café cran à une
copine quand en payant très cher vous
pouvez changer de signes du zodiaque et
oui quand on a un signe pourri comme
capricorne
c'est votre signe bon ça va non
sinon je suis poisson
ascendant balance et et dragons
j'ai une passion pour les manteaux vrai
mais on hermine tacheté
ah oui alors le problème c'est que
j'étais un petit peu c'est même un petit
et passages difficiles dans ma vie
j'avais pris un tube entier de lexomil
un jour que je devais tourner donc je ne
me souviens pas du tout ce film et je ne
les ai jamais revus
et même et un plan c'est même pas moins
qu'ils jouent dedans c'est ma soeur qui
était stagiaire script sur le sujet je
suis pas venu avec c'est ce que j'avais
avalé je suis pas venu tourner donc on a
pris ma soeur et lescure est passée par
là et des 10 mai et vous avez pris
valérie lemercier vous lui faites pas un
gros plan le disait pas elle c'est sa
première fois que ça m'arrive est la
dernière j'espère mais donc je je n'ai
en fait j'ai un petit trou de mémoire de
ce passage de ma vie
non je n'ai pas menti donc alors c'est
vrai que j'ai menti ou c'est faux que
faux je n'ai pas menti
mais pas vendu mon césar sur le bon coin
c'est ça que vous pensez
enfin j'en ai deux je voulais montrer si
vous voulez y habite pas loin